RECKLESSNESS AND EXTREMISM.
>> Jesse: I'M SO EXTREME.
IS HERE TO RESPOND FORMER
COUNSELOR TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
KELLYANNE.
DON'TER WITH ABOUT THE SHOOTING.
I'M THE EXTREMIST.
>> I THINK YOU ARE GREAT FOR THE
RATINGS.
JESSE DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
BY THE WAY CONGRATULATIONS ON
WATTERS UNIVERSE.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS TIME WHEN
WE WERE IN THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
WE HEARD THE WORD CHAOS, CHAOS,
CHAOS IN HIS TWEETS.
CHAOS IN OFF HANDED REMARK.
NOW THERE IS CHAOS WHICH MEANS
UNCERTAINTY, INSECURITY, TURMOIL
EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK.
>> CHAOS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
CHAOS AT THE GAS PUMP.
CHAOS AT THE GROCERY STORE.
CHAOS IN UKRAINE.
CHAOS IN WIZ LOOKING PRICES.
CHAOS IN OUR SCHOOL.
CHAOS IN WORKPLACES.
CAN WE GO BACK?
PEOPLE FEEL THAT INSECURITY AND
UNCERTAINTY NOW AND MORE THAN
THAT, THEY ARE BLAMING JOE BIDEN
CLOSE TO 70% DON'T WANT HIM TO
RUN AGAIN.
IT'S NOT JUST JOE BIDEN, EITHER.
IT'S HIS VICE PRESIDENT SUN
POPULAR AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
SO THOSE WERE LINING UP AND
SALIVATING THAT WE'LL GET RID OF
INCAPACITATED JOE DON'T REALIZE
THEY WILL STILL HAVE THE
INCOMPETENT DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
THEY ARE PART OF IT THESE FOOLS
WENT INTO HIS CABINET.
THEY VOTED FOR HIS TERRIBLE
LEGISLATION ON CAPITOL HILL.
SO THEY ARE LIKE JOE BIDEN,
JESSE, THEY ARE GOING TO OWN AND
EAT ALL OF HIS POLICIES, CRIME,
IT'S JUST LIKE 194 ALL OVER
AGAIN.
I WORKED CONTRACT OF AMERICA
FRANK LUNTZ, NEWT GINGRICH WITH
HALEY BARBOUR AND THAT CONTRACT
WITH AMERICA BY THE TIME WE WERE
POLLING THE PUBLIC AND POLLING
CANDIDATES AND OFFICE HOLDERS
AND OTHER OPINION CRIME WAS UP
THERE AS A TOP ISSUE.
GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE POLLS IN
THE SUMMER OF 1994.
SEEING THAT ALL OVER AGAIN.
IT MEANS THAT SECURITY AND
AFFORDABILITY ARE THE TWO THEMES
GOING INTO THESE TWO MIDTERMS.
ON BOTH JOE BIDEN SCORES VERY
POORLY.
>> Jesse: CABLE NETWORKS ARE
DENYING CRIME IS A PROBLEM.
I DON'T SEE HOW THAT IS GOING TO
SOLVE THEIR CREDIBILITY CRISIS.
THAT'S JUST IDIOCY.
SOMETHING HAPPENED TODAY.
I'M A LITTLE BIT JEALOUS BECAUSE
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN TO ME.
WE'LL SET IT UP THIS WAY.
REMEMBER WHEN JOE BIDEN SAID ON
HIS FIRST DAY IN OFFICE?
ROLL IT.
>> I'M NOT JOKING WHEN I SAY
THIS.
IF YOU EVER WORKING WITH ME AND
I HEAR YOU TREAT ANOTHER
COLLEAGUE WITH DISRESPECT, TALK
DOWN TO SOMEONE, I PROMISE YOU I
WILL FIRE YOU ON THE SPOT.
ON THE SPOT.
>> Jesse: WELL, JOE MIGHT NOT
REALIZE IT BUT HE IS FIRED.
LISTEN.
>> WILL YOU TAKE QUESTIONS ON
INFLATION THEN?
>> LISTEN.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU ALL.
>> DO YOU THINK INFLATION IS A
POLITICAL LIABILITY ON MIDTERMS.
>> THAT'S A GREAT ASSET.
FOR INFLATION.
WHAT A STUPID SON OF A BITCH.
>> Jesse: I'M THE ONLY ONE
THAT'S ALLOWED TO SAY THAT THE
PRESIDENT CAN'T SAY THAT.
>> THEY ARE WORKING OVERTIME
SOCIAL MEDIA I'M SURE WITH THE
WHAT ABOUTISM.
AND TRUMP, ET CETERA.
THIS IS THE SECOND TIME IN A
WEEK THAT A FOX NEWS WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT HAS BEEN DERIDED
AND CASTIGATED BY THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Jesse: JACQUI HEINRICH.
I HATE TWITTER BUT I TWEETED OUT
JACKIE WAS ACCUSED OF ASKING A
QUOTE STUPID QUESTION IT WAS
EXCELLENT AND TIMELY QUESTION
ABOUT SANCTIONS AGAINST RUSSIA
AND THERE PRESIDENT BIDEN CALLED
HER QUESTION STUPID.
HERE HE CALLED THE ACTUAL
REPORTER STUPID.
BUT THIS IS A GUY WHO THAT SAME
NBC NEWS POLL, JESSE, IS SEEN AS
NO LONGER EASY GOING AND
LIKEABLE.
SO HIS PERSONAL ATTRIBUTES HAVE
CRATERED ALONG WITH JOB APPROVAL
OF THESE MAJOR ISSUES.
AND THIS IS A GUY, REMEMBER HE
SAID HE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
DONALD TRUMP OUT BEHIND THE HIGH
SCHOOL GYMNASIUM AND PUNCH HIM
IN THE NOSE?
THIS IS A GUY WITH A TERRIBLE
TEMPER.
NOT TAKING HAPPY PILLS ON THE
WEEKEND IN WILMINGTON, CLEARLY.
ON THE SERIOUS POINT ON THE
CRIME THING QUICKLY GEORGE
GASCON IN L.A.
LARRY KRASNER IN PHILADELPHIA,
ALVIN BRAGG HERE IN MANHATTAN,
THESE ARE GUYS, THEY ARE FORCING
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO RETIRE
EARLY, TO RESIGN.
THEY ARE NOT ARRESTING.
THEY ARE DOING NO CASH BAIL.
THEY ENHANCED SENTENCINGS ARE
HAPPENING IN L.A. THE TRAIN
PEOPLE, UNITED PACIFIC ASKED FOR
HELP WITH THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS.
CRIMINALS RANSACK AND HAVE A
SECOND CHANCE TO DO THE SAME
WEEK THIS DISEEROUS.
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE MOM
SIDES.
WE HAD 12 CITIES BREAKING
HOMICIDE RECORDS LAST YEAR ON
JOE BIDEN'S WATCH.
IT'S A REAL THING.
>> Jesse: IF BIDEN WOULD GET AS
ANGRY AS HE DID WITH PETER DOOCY
ABOUT CRIME IN THIS COUNTRY, I
THINK PEOPLE WOULD RESPECT THAT
A LOT MORE.
>> IT'S A DEMOCRATIC PROBLEM NOT
JUST A JOE BIDEN